those who said console gaming was dying
were proven dead wrong yet again both
the PlayStation 4 and Xbox one appeared
to have had a successful black friday
with the two consoles being among the
top sellers this past Friday according
to a new report Adobe sales report for
Black Friday identifies the two consoles
along with the Samsung 4k TVs the ipad
air 2 and the ipad mini has five of the
best selling electronic devices in terms
of best-selling toys lego dimensions
made the list during its first black
friday another detailed to note from the
report is the fact that the playstation
4 version of NBA 2k16 was one of the
five products most likely to sell out of
this included the Amazon fire tablet and
beats headphones responding to a tweet
about sold out xbox one bundles Xbox
marketing boss aaron greenberg said on
Twitter that Microsoft has heard the
Xbox one had really strong black friday
sales those strong sales may continue
through today for both consoles thanks
to cyber monday both are discounted as
are a number of games the Wii U and more
for a full list of some of the best
cyber monday deals follow the link below
you